alright guys welcome back to the Jenna
and Julian podcast
you shouldn't high-five ralpherz hi Rob
this is our special guest at the wheel
this is yeah Rob I know Rob is our good
friend and he is also a very very
talented youtuber if you want to call
that he creates amazing videos on his
channel
it's the Rob deck right yeah yeah you
you but you do a whole bunch of [ __ ]
will get all into your stuff will get
all up in your stuff in yourself that's
happened twice today yeah that's it
happens god but we're so happy to have
her off here it's [ __ ] great when we
have like her good friends able to join
us mark especially when they don't live
here which is great it's cute it is cute
you're cute thank you
this podcast is brought to you by me and
easily uh that's it that's why we want
to raise a favor and we don't just
normally have underwear on our table we
do it for the me and it's because me
undies is some of the most comfortable
underwear you can buy it's the most
comfortable on the market we wear it all
the time and I say it's made of
somewhere it don't worry it's made of
something we likewise and show that's
twice as soft as cotton mmm and it is
I'm telling you it keeps it cool it
stays in place me undies is where you
can get your pair check it out and go to
me Eddie's calm slash Jim Julian for 20%
off your first purchase we will get into
that later more we'll talk about
underwear more later that should get me
undies yes me IDs that's not a thing it
should be that's good wait did they hire
you because they should I'm a plant yeah
this really shifts over after this thank
you for using our panties this all right
well I guess
well Rob's in town you're in town for
VidCon yes which just ended this last
weekend and you live in Massachusetts
hmm and we net mm-hm
playlists yes yes we'd uh it was
playlist tri-state tri-state we met you
there and represent and we uh we were
immediately like in love with you we
call we call
I'm dad dad dad Sabir isn't it yeah and
the hugs yeah give dad hugs yeah well I
can see me okay
are we like the same house you 28 I'm 27
I'm 28 notch over so it's really not
weird for me to call him dad yeah still
sometimes but it's possible it's
possible that if they'll call you dad if
like like in relationships occur it's
completely possible oh yeah oh yeah yeah
you could be you can hear yeah like if
like if your mom marries someone that's
like 12 and you're like 30 yeah you know
what I mean like my mom did then that
would did you yes yeah exactly yeah okay
so just a quick I guess intro Rob makes
videos on YouTube but you do a kind of a
variety of different videos you have a
series called seriously strange you have
a series called wild you put on the
internet and before I get to why why
would you put them on the air which I
love I was watching some seriously
strange today and uh that shit's [ __ ]
dark yeah then I like it and there's a
thing about that show which I'm going to
call a show because the way you produce
it you have that team put it together
it's not an edition video yeah alright
that's what I went for
yeah sorry can I do that the whole time
no I'm not gonna do that
um he's gonna punch you if you do that
cuz he'll come alive and he'll just come
out here that's alright once - I've been
eyeballing him all day yeah he's great
yeah they're creme de drippy anyway I
like creepy though right that's come you
do and that's great but so what you
what's amazing is you have developed
this giant audience on the internet
watching your videos and they are
they're not just lists of things you go
into detail of why you would pick
something like this to be in that
episode yeah and it's like you you you
have this presence about you where
you're incredibly you can't like look
away because you're just like so
interested in Yuki you're hosting it
well but at the same time you're not
[ __ ] around like this isn't some joke
you know I mean like you host it
seriously but you have a charm about
that what made you want to start doing
videos that were about things like
interest in seriously strange is he
hitting on me
yes okay I thought we established that
um beautiful yeah that's gotta be good
especially once the cameras off um what
I did I realized I'll play elder scrolls
well that happens sorry keep them no you
you're gonna have to do your the audio
person yeah I mean whatever but we'll
talk about we don't have to talk about
now uh I figure people are multifaceted
a lot of people like comedy like horror
and I my background was in criminal
justice
I studied serial killers and criminal
behavior and everything like that for a
while and I was known by my professor
who was the former colonel of State
Police of Massachusetts as his serial
killer expert so if he ever had a
question about serial killers he would
ask me and because I just don't fit to
them so much and I love them it's really
[ __ ] awesome
like I'm not I haven't gone so far down
the rabbit hole of serial killers but I
love like [ __ ] Dateline or like
anything that has to do with murders and
it gets a little sketchy in your own
brain sometimes when you're like why
would I like this so much yeah I yeah
ever ever lonely like that we really
want it like this though yeah it
happened when I was very young and I
murdered my first prostitute
yeah why did I like so much quiet four
years old man I found my hobby how did I
even get the prostitute but uh then I
went on to be a private investigator for
a short amount of time which was Anna
bodyguard
which is really cool but also boring
yeah you didn't want but I mean
different types of details right you
were yeah I did like for instance one
job obviously I can never mention name
ever in my life but that's how it was a
woman coming out of witness protection
what she wasn't supposed to do because
her son was getting married um the
certain motorcycle club decided to blow
up her house so um she ever since went
into that she came out for son's wedding
we had to provide executive protection
as what we called it for that that was
one thing I do too much of that a lot of
it was just um you know tracking down
cheating spouses
people for workman's comp there you know
screwing the system and then some car
chases which were weird there was one
guys wanted by the FBI and nobody could
tell them because he like picked up on
it and I ended up they sent it they sent
me out to do it which is stupid because
I was not experienced at all driving the
car and chasing someone
I was I was following him sometimes you
have to blow lights to make sure you can
like keep up with them um like you they
don't know you're chasing so it's not
like this crazy thing what you are you
don't know what right you've gotta
follow them so they went through a light
it's turning red doesn't matter get
through the light because otherwise
you're going to lose them that and this
guy all of a sudden he's driving down
and he he takes a right and I take a
right and I'm keeping back from him and
all of a sudden he takes another right
and I take another right he takes
another right and then another right and
another right and I realize holy [ __ ]
I've been following this guy for like 20
minutes and work going around his
neighborhood and he knows I'm behind him
and then all of a sudden I had to bail
because he knew and so that that on that
so that kind of background
I had the comedy I was always like funny
a lot of people meet me and they are
surprised that I'm not like a serial
killer but um whatever the [ __ ] you
don't know about surprise you don't know
[ __ ] about me and don't kill us
yeah and we don't right I'm not going to
I find that very interesting not not
only that you have such a passion and
kind of interest in the dark things that
you talk about the you know serial
killers stuff like that but the fact
that you are able to have such a
variation in the content you make you
have a complete dark side and you have a
complete [ __ ] hilarious side that's
very internet II and you are you turn it
on like you're funny
in in why would you put that on you know
that's some really funny [ __ ] like you
know there's this hard when you know
you're well but I think there's a lot
a lot of shows mirrors there's a lot of
shows that take things and you're
basically left to react to them writing
the content and you do a good job at do
you do you feel like like you have to
turn it on what you know when you can do
in the funny [ __ ] and then you're not
you know um I I don't have to turn on
anything luckily not yet I mean there
have been things that I've had to do or
you have to turn on a certain aspect of
yourself but when it comes to comedy I I
never I have like a small handful of
times on a 100 project of that on the
internet so does almost 98 yeah a nice
big hug people once 100 comes it's it's
done yeah
he's ending it at a hundred it's done I
didn't really yes done I hate it it's
sooo crude it doesn't keep up with
everything else really admirable yeah
you know and I appreciate that and I
thought and it comes at a risk but
whatever you get it went into this
business not to work for anybody else I
work for myself right and I make my
decisions okay so that's what I'm doing
but on the comedy aspect I never
scripted an episode of watch put that on
the Internet
I just I just type out the submission so
I know what I'm reading and then I just
went off on each and I tried to do it
where I would see the submission read it
and then immediately save it and don't
think about it and try to get that
genuine reaction for like the first time
absolutely yeah and that's what I would
do with that seriously strange I've just
every now and then you're just in this
mood where it just clicks on you don't
have to like really switch anything and
I'm just ready to go with it and yeah
that's tool I don't know it's not it's
not it's not tough to do it's not tough
it's cool natural I don't know about all
that well no I mean I mean in the grand
scheme it is but in terms of like acting
or being dark
yeah and knowing I mean once you hear
about all this girl was kidnapped and
they found her arms and then her legs
and then her had six months later it's
like it almost like just switches you
for exactly you know do you find there's
like a different like OS that was on
purpose you find there's a you have
different audiences watching the
different videos like you know because
obviously you familiar with your
audience but do different sections of
them watch only one of the videos yeah a
lot of them
our one or the other a lot of them are
both but plenty of people are lodged
with that on the internet diehard fans
and I don't blame them it's fine but uh
you know they're like we're going on
subscribe once it's over so I'm like
okay I won't end it till the new shows
out so you have to give it a chance
that's I mean like like John was just
saying that's a big power move and it's
awesome that you've decided to make that
step in in realizing you know hey I
think in whatever you think goes because
it's your [ __ ] but I think you know 100
episodes is is time and you're going to
end something that's doing well which is
something that a lot of people can't do
and they're scared to do right you know
and it's really cool and I feel like
it's you know to bring an analogy and
it's like when you watch we're big fans
of MMA and when we watch fighters that
we've watched for years and we love them
they they they very rarely retire on
their own terms
yeah a lot of the time we'll fight and
fight and fight until you know people
are given them subliminal messages like
hey hang it up you know and it's so hard
to see that I hate that but it's so hard
for them to put it down early because
they love that and they that's their
bread and butter
similar to why'd you put that on the
internet in some ways yeah I'm trying to
think of people that have stopped like
series on YouTube before cuz I know ray
william johnson had stopped doing equals
three years it's done it's go live yeah
burn house but at least you know when he
announced that that was sort of a big
deal for the internet when people are
like oh [ __ ] like people might stop
making content for us cuz they don't
want to anymore yeah it's like it's a
possibility right obviously you'll get
backlash and people will be upset but at
the end of the day like you know you
need to make you happy and that's why I
was like it's really [ __ ] like that's
a big deal it's so [ __ ] like you're
standing up for yourself you're like
cool this pays my bills then you know
it's great and I'm glad you guys like it
but I don't wanna do it anymore
nice that's the end of it that's uh I've
never had any problem and I established
that early I didn't cater and I have no
problem telling people every now and
then if they just keep running their
mouth to just be like sit down and shut
your [ __ ] mouth or go away yeah
yeah and I have no problem with that if
people go you know untie an almond
subscribing there's a difference between
constructive criticism which i think is
important to take because you have a you
have an audience a lot of people and a
lot of them are telling you really good
[ __ ] right and how much do companies pay
to test like so control like groups of
people okay to get what their product
how their product will do on the market
and you get that for free and just
upload and they tell you thank you like
if you're an actor you don't get that
kind of feedback you might get a review
or something but like you're not
constantly like being told on a regular
basis how good you're doing right now
all right right
it's very embattled you're right
absolutely and it's important to
distinguish the hate comments to just
pure trolling and then the constructive
criticism because if hell yes it's hard
to see criticism but you're absolutely
right listening to your viewers is cute
yeah it's huge
yes they they well they want something
amazing and I think a lot of people do
and you know they're like geez oh man
it's so close only if it had this and
I've taken fan suggestions before yeah
if I see a suggestion that pops up like
a number of times like I'll like heavily
consider doing it because you're the
same way you get the number of what same
idea yeah I adore it and they look
alright [ __ ] made this for you yeah
except I made it know what you wanted
but at least I made it yeah at least
I'll listen blowme subscribe Samir I had
a million well not recently kind of like
a couple months ago
that's how about that about a couple
months ago do like a million o2 now a
million group sorry is that plus if you
can make a whole video of that you'll
live there so well I'm I I am right now
approaching 1.8 oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me that's
awesome dude all right yeah I mean ya
know did you have 1 million in what
February uh it was it early
might have been I think I hit I hit 1
million on the flight here for the first
time and I want to say that was either
February or March so cool that's growth
right there that's awesome really yeah
that was cool I every time I come here
for some reason like like I get a boost
and I don't even do anything yes it's
just like okay I was in LA so I can
expect something to happen yeah it was
cool I think I hit something like some
number like that when I was driving to
LA I think it happens for a lot of
people you're like on my way there for
the first time ever and you're like oh
oh my cool does this like dammit I
didn't get to do anything that everyone
doesn't just refresh the page oh you
didn't get the screen show me I was
already like a thousand over by the time
the plane landed in like Oh fuck-you
thousand unsub now big screen drop for
you no because because how uh you know
updates on the fans and this is like an
updates in these huge chunks there's
like live counters you can find but yeah
that's fine you never know yeah exactly
which channel is that that just hit one
point eight or is it that's my main
channel just Rob Dyke yeah so you put
both series of videos on that channel
yeah which isn't suggested but it works
yeah at what yeah I can buy my passion
for comedy and dark criminal you know
[ __ ]
yeah instead I'm gonna do both and a lot
of people said don't and I said okay too
bad I'm doing I do what I want be at
various on here you guys ever want to
comment honestly it's really just don't
just like wing it you you have like
stats oh you have a teeny upset I mean
it's professional as [ __ ] like it's not
a joke I try to I I think that was
hugely important for me was making
making a set if it's a different show
I'm you know I I feel in if it's a show
and the same set works for a lot of
people because it's not like a show that
they're doing but if you're talking
about you know joking around about
someone who takes pictures of you know
weed in their nose or some [ __ ] like
that and then you cross over into a baby
being thrown out of a plane which both
are hilarious
but but you know you've got a you've got
to really have a different look for that
and that was something I was always huge
on like put something behind you and
everyone who asks for like advice like
what should I do
so if you're gonna do a show do it make
a set yeah and just like show time into
it yeah right really makes a lot of
difference my first WOD you put that on
the internet set cost me 11 dollars
really together my seriously strange
that's all right now teach us your ways
11 going great Amazon is where we're
rocking the sound foam set yeah right
it's functional but it looks like sound
foam yeah so it looks like it it
definitely well definitely yeah it is it
that's actual sound food so how many set
you have you three sets yes finalists
Aisha Puri I want them done on the
internet no twisted chances heart yes
miss attends is getting its own but um I
have seriously strange has its own and
then I have serial killer files which I
made one part of the room look like this
old like no are like Detective private
investigator kind of like so but you
have personal experience taken over your
whole life like your whole house um it's
actually occasion it's my old bedroom in
my parents house so I just I like pay
them rent just to help them out and
stuff like that because uh you know if
you can you help people out that's right
that's a rule if you're able to help you
you help family especially family
especially especially especially if they
helped you get to where you need to be
yeah which they did so my old bedroom I
just said hey I'm gonna do this and back
then I was like making barely any money
any any success at all and I'm just like
just hold on I swear it'll you know yeah
like $11 was like a tenth of what I made
you know I love like sometimes it was
just like just hold on and it'll get
better and it does yeah some people
don't get that stuff it's some people
just like I got a comment recently um
are you late for your shift it you know
Burger King or something like it's just
like do you really think like YouTube
you can make money off of youtube
YouTube can be a job you can it can be
it is true if you work hard enough and
it's not too late a lot of people think
it's too late and I've thought it's too
late before sometimes
with all the changes YouTube is it's so
hard it's harder now used to be put
someone in the sub box and forget it
you're off yeah that doesn't do jack
anymore but I've seen enough people have
a lot of success even now they grow
really fast yeah yeah I thought I was
late I thought I was truly just arty I
definitely thought I was too late I had
that thought go through my mind before I
mean yours does like I've noticed that
like your vlogs definitely pay off
because it's just like you get really
good views yeah I mean it's like this
blog sucks and it did really well no
your vlogs are like actually fun to
[ __ ] watch because the jump cuts
happened like well yeah it resets my
damn mind
oh I think pretty sets I get really
quick can we talk about me yes good I
was gonna make a transition saying
speaking of your bedroom you're gonna
have the transition or your bedroom so
90 percent of your life you're wearing
underwear not really [ __ ] sure what
the other 10% is no showing gorgeous
wait a minute n % of your life has been
showering showering that showering uh
[ __ ] maybe swimmin in your life or
naked lunges getting born pretty good
wedding for anyway you're wearing
underwear all the time it's worth more
than a good pair these underwear mandis
they make quality [ __ ] and you will
never ever like be able to go back
because it's just soft it keeps you cool
and the elastic doesn't read so many
times I feel like I've looked up like
what's the best kind of underwear I
could buy I'll spend a little more and
then it rips I'm like [ __ ] you you don't
I mean your underwear rips all the time
it does and these haven't ripped and
I've worn them for months I know I can
tell every time you wearing you me
undies because they look like this Golic
they have electric designs a really cool
stuff check it out at Mandy's comm
you'll get 20% off if you go to me
Andy's calm sloshed Jenna Julianne
that's Mei nice calm / annejulien and
also say you buy it and you're like [ __ ]
this sucks
you just return it and they'll refund
you a hundred percent so there's no harm
done check it out me at ease Dundee
Thank You Mandy's for sponsoring I want
to put your beer me undies on your penis
and
oh yes no matter because gender is a
social construct so there's no matter
what you are you can you put that in
your video ha ha yeah yeah no anyways I
was about to say yeah we're talking
about on my blog something right yeah no
I what both of you guys do make it seem
really easy to be successful on YouTube
because clearly what you make just
appears as like a vlog and then most
people don't realize until they pick up
a camera and try and start vlogging like
how many shots you have like how much
time you put into just editing the music
or making it seem like a coherent day or
like any sort of the time lapses that
you put in it you don't need it's a lot
of [ __ ] work every single day and
people don't realize it until they start
to try they just sort of watch it no
this one's weaker door but I mean you
put a lot more work into it than people
know yeah I was robbed you you build
yourself an entire set you have your
material set every single week you do
all of your stuff it's a lot harder than
people think until they actually try and
do it and there's I don't like when
people say things like oh you just got
lucky or they try and chalk up what you
do to particular things that make no
sense yeah it's hard work across the
board and no I don't think that anybody
really gets lucky sure I mean yeah right
even like a little [ __ ] boys well
there's lows in all day every day
exactly even if you do get lucky once
you either capitalize it or you don't or
yeah you know how many people have gone
like viral and where are they exactly
the exact and capitalize on it properly
yeah oh man
well I was so I was a viral video right
well I think now viral is very different
like you can be viral I'm fine you could
be viral
pollito yeah final thought your eyes can
be the article it's different cuz we're
not all of our eyes aren't pointed in
the same direction anymore they're kind
of all over the place yeah but I was you
know a viral video and I was told by
which there's no reason not to admit
that by the way ya know evil who are
products of our videos
I would you ever say I'm not a product
of our but if you are you are it's in
the proof is in the pudding you are U&I
made a really really really really like
fire video internet [ __ ] apart I mean
it could have just like disappeared
which was no chance yeah but um I was
told by a lot of people that I should be
like selling more things or just trying
to like ride the wave yeah and I was
sort of scoffed out people are like what
do you mean you want to just keep doing
that like nah this seems like a more
logical path yeah no people want when
they say capitalise they want you to
Bank like now like a chain yeah make the
merch yeah go out and then just fizzle
out okay and so many people do that
maybe I won't like your plan and that's
how you're clean and that's on my plan I
don't think I've done a really good job
doing that yeah well I appreciate it a
lot
yeah I mean there's a lot of talent at
this table what are we going to do after
this I think we're gonna probably just
sit and compliment one another one
another and uh tip with alcohol involve
maybe a minute then it's just
yeah the compliments start turning into
like passive-aggressiveness good and
then just start fighting and then I
storm out yeah oh wow really yeah um and
I know you said you work on a new show
to Congress in place of watch Pathan
yeah is there anything that you can say
about that is by a splendid sneak peek I
will all right Rob Dyke it will be I
will be in it so um so I haven't
publicly except I mentioned it like once
on Twitter I definitely haven't
mentioned it online like in a video at
all but yeah oh no just I would love to
oh is this is this breaking room I would
love to do it [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
then just complete do it over me talking
Sonu
here's a new show is bear-bear DJ Kelly
so it's going to be called social
autopsy and it's kind of a fusion
between seriously strange and why would
you put that on the Internet
I'm actually designing going to be
designing a new set which I love that's
a really good name keep going thank you
yeah um so what I do is I take all the
social [ __ ] that's going around all the
time and I talk about that so it's kind
of talking about stupidity but maybe
stupid any people aren't aware of I'm
gonna take like the social issues people
like yeah definitely that's a good thing
yeah I don't explain why it's not or
what cost it comes
so you're basically debunk all the
people who think they know every right
yeah a little bit it's a more
intelligent form out of the shell play
I'm actually designing another set which
is going to be tough with moving but
I'll make it happen somehow I'm moving
I'm moving here oh I'm moving here thank
you was I drunk when you don't you might
have been well no was it at VidCon
because I was just yeah doctor right
before VidCon which basically is like
not telling you at all cuz that's that's
preparing to drink that's justice I like
jumped around to me yeah yeah I'm moving
out here kitty-kitty coming I'm gonna
cry I'm so happy I didn't know that you
guys holding on to this secret I might
not that's not my fault even dude
awesome you told it you know what me you
talk sometimes you know I'm like gluing
on eyelashes on my face and I'm really
not listening you know and I think the
fact that big comes like tomorrow you're
like I can't even hear what you're
saying yeah so you're good like you're
moving sets that'll be kind of yeah I'm
gonna try and physically move all the
stuff with you oh I'm probably just
gonna build new things and change it up
because that's kind of what I like to do
and I have a toll excuse to do that but
I'm going to try to reconstruct like a
morgue setting I'm gonna like I want a
gurney I want like a chalkboard that I
can let go like ham on they say
I'm like doing everything and just going
crazy it's gonna be awesome
I think it'll be good hopefully I mean I
could I know how good it is is really up
to me and how i listened to the audience
and how receptive they are cuz i do need
their help then i think that any creator
who does that is on a road to success
right well i think that your show
whatever you do first of all you're a
better host than most of the hosts on
television that are doing this year
forty it's terrible
I'd say yeah all right is what Rob wants
and no one on TV can ever mimic that
because they in a box and Rob's done
he's completely on his own he's doing
whatever right and I think that what you
just said like speaks volumes so like
it's only as good as I make it and I'm
gonna make it really [ __ ] down so
that's released and that's all that's
like it's a scary thing but it's also
the most motivating thing ever like I
have complete control of how well this
does just by how much I play and then a
lot that's the thing I've been asked
that a lot I think I think everyone has
if you're on YouTube you've been asked
did you think it was going to work and I
think anybody can have it like that
doubts every now and then but I shoved
that [ __ ] right out of my head anytime
that came up and I said this is up to me
and there's no other option it will
happen and that's it and that's the
bottom line
and okay and if this doesn't work I will
just do something else it I mean it's
like the Michael Scott Paper Company
absolutely it shows you shut down
Michael Palin come they're gonna go
build another Michael Scott paper
writing I have unlimited amount of names
there Michael that's what Oh he's
finishing my office quotes you need to
stay a period man whatever understands
my office rep oh my god I love you um oh
my god I just like hearing you talk
right now that like that last bit while
you were talking about if it doesn't
work I gotta move
that's how successful people think and
that's how they act and it's and it's
just very very very like take [ __ ]
note because people who do things
whatever they do and they are successful
at them sometimes they are very talented
but sometimes they have the mindset and
this drive and the way they act and the
way they are constructed and how they
conduct themselves when it comes to work
they can ever fail no matter what right
everything can come crashing down on
them and they will come through it and
succeed no matter no matter
Rob just you know the way he explains
that it's just it's very key like
embodies that attitude which is awesome
and it's it's no coincidence that you
are doing well and your channel is doing
well and can you walk in and you have
complete contrasting content on one
channel and people still subscribe like
a polarizing [ __ ] like funny and then
really dark and people subscribe anyway
yeah you know it's crazy it's really
cool yeah I appreciate it and I don't
take all them as very well I know it's
like I don't know no it doesn't mean I
trust me no I just try to identify that
my dad you know no I really appreciate
them I think it's important that people
get it too and and I like just like
ignore my awkwardness but like I've
never handled them well I come from a
time in my life where um compliments
were sometimes deceptive on purpose to
strengthen me so I don't really and I
don't think your compliments are I just
that's how I like everyone was a trophy
kind of thing yeah and and it's and I
know I have so much work to do and
everything and like I know and I
appreciate so much you feel that way but
I just you know never like compliments
like distract you too much you know what
I mean I think that's how people end up
buying into their own hype they have so
many people telling them like do holy
[ __ ] like you're the next you know
Hendricks you know and all of a sudden
the [ __ ] thinks that they don't
have to play guitar is harder yeah you
know what I mean absolutely right have
you seen the movie whiplash yet no last
time to us I think I I don't know
possibly but I mean anyone who has seen
it I think probably knows where I'm
going with it but um we should got to
watch that no it's a good movie but I
won't spoil it but it's about you could
tell by the trailer that's about a
teacher who's considered abusive he's a
music teacher to this one to all of his
students but especially to a new kid
who's a drummer coming into their jazz
orchestra and he ends up getting this
point things you know I mean he's over
the top and he ends up sitting with the
kid later and the kid goes and he just
goes you know I'm trying to like inspire
and create the next legendary person and
he says that
there's no two words deadlier in the
English language other than good job
because so many people here good job and
they just stopped trying as hard Mia and
in the kid ass and both don't you think
there's a line don't you think you might
discourage the next big person the next
legend and he goes no because the next
legend would never be discouraged by
anything yeah and I think that's what
you have to take into this and if you
want to be successful you need to
understand that shit's gonna hit the fan
people are going to tell you to kill
yourself get the [ __ ] over it yeah just
don't do it you know I don't do that but
come on I mean it's the internet they
don't have to face you face to face it's
cowardice anyway you know as soon as you
start listening and taking it's a like
Game of Thrones yeah you know the lion
doesn't concern himself with the opinion
of the Sheep yeah um I mean that's
really what it is not the thing that
sure that takes some compliments like
some things some things are valuable to
hear oh actually like at least for me or
for other people that maybe like
sometimes when I like when my mom tells
me good job I get really excited of
habit yeah um it's to never be satisfied
with yourself I think helps me you know
what I mean like if people are gonna say
oh this is great or whatever look I'm
never truly satisfied before what I'm
doing and it makes you want to keep
doing more joining me right now you
should compliment be like a guy you know
you're on the right track right do it
right but just don't let it all comes
your desire boom Bravo I like just don't
let it you know like yeah we just like
you don't want it diminish you don't
want it out what it water you'd
absolutely you know because we've said
is what I do water you down yeah yeah
we've seen soup about seeing what turns
you right into Crystal Light yeah but to
get to her table is like Crystal Light
mmm thank you so much you said crystal
crystal like I asked her to say that
I was like listen shiny Janica I was
like hey Jenna nice to meet you by the
way if we ever end up doing a podcast at
any point cuz you just mentioned Crystal
Light somewhere she's like what the [ __ ]
are you that how drunk are you doesn't
get out guy get out of the girls
bathroom their game where we play where
you try and just as inconspicuously as
possible and as many times as possible
we've guy fieri into the conversation
how about Guy Fieri with uh with dark
hair and I haven't seen it again can we
look that up yeah Guy Fieri um without
the blonde hair without the like
completely white blonde hair I'm gonna
rock your world and he's gonna see it
first have you seen it yet no I have not
he's gonna see it first
yeah see I'm sure you guys probably saw
his picture because it's horrifying and
then you're gonna and his reactions
gonna tell you everything you need to
know well this is seriously strange talk
Oh oh yeah okay oh my god make it big
make it big make it oh my god
that's horrifying just restarted no no I
got my phone this podcast brought to you
why might she go just Guy Fieri with
dark hair back hair oh my god that's
horrible
oh I can't even believe what I just saw
that's not him I know it's bad it's
awful I'll not go see this is it look he
looks like a meatball yeah yeah oh my
god he looks like somebody's Italian oh
he looks oh [ __ ] oh god he looks like
paul Blart no wonder he got a [ __ ]
heron's facial which let's not huh he
does not wear me honey something that he
doesn't [ __ ] that guy does not do I'm
not even famous um Rob thanks so much
for joining us on this well thank you
for having me I should initiate it so
much this is this is awesome yeah I feel
like you know people are gonna get good
kick I guess is the coolest we just say
our goal
and I'm gonna link all the robbed stuff
below his channel his stuff go and check
him out seriously give it a try if you
hate it [ __ ] it
don't don't watch it again but it's
worth giving up Russia all this stuff
you don't like it when people isn't wide
wide variety of things that you can be
entertained by on his channel and his
Twitter is also very fun to follow so
we'll link all that below I'm done whew
yeah yeah if you dare all the way your
own risk
thank you me Andes for sponsoring the
podcast you me nd 20% off guys me Andes
calm / Jenna Julian that's em eunbi's
calm spoken employee discount yeah
that's nice
put it in hippie free wrong it's um you
don't get [ __ ] anything but they might
send you an email and ask you what was
wrong and you can possibly be added to
like the NSA watchlist who knows like
you know I bet if you put Rob you send
him an email
I bet you they'll give you the 20%
anyway oh you know what let's put that
to the test and actually no put Jenna
Julian so you can guarantee your show
points out yeah and then put Rob and get
another 20 and then put Rob to and get
another two and buy all their me undies
and then sell them yourself and do and
call it you undies Rob secretly founded
me and easiest intros
yeah do you think me on these old undies
thank you for coming out of podcast yeah
well thank you for having me I love this
hold on now one last time that's a
really hard one Carly good thanks
no it's good it since it's like a skill
I all I can do is like inhale and choke
on yeah well everyone's got to get
something right I'm really good at that
see you guys next week for another
podcast yeah bye fancy leader